[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number
135. it's odd but it's not prime
anyone knows that anyone come on
multiples of five it's so simple yeah
um i am dr brett weinstein this is dr
heather heing and uh we have a train to
catch so this is going to be
to the point yeah this is going to be
rapid fire uh we are not going to be
doing a q a today apologies for that but
uh we'll come back next week uh with
with more questions we can't with more
of your questions and more of our
answers we can't stop you from cueing no
we cannot stop you from queueing
and uh and here
cueing right in front of the camera is
our darkest cat i have a feeling that's
spelled differently but i can't be
certain of that queuing and queueing
yeah yeah i mean queueing
q a isn't really a word it's not a word
yeah no queuing yeah
yeah exactly they scoffed at yeah in
polite circles yeah no queueing
q-u-e-i-n-g
bizarre yeah too many vowels anyway here
we are yeah here we are it is mid-july
it is almost the end of july
and uh we're going to talk to you about
um
about a little covety stuff and uh
a few things yeah we're gonna do a
little kind of a way back machine that
needs doing um
about uh how to know when you're being
lied to things like that excellent okay
uh let's do logistics first let's get
let's get all this out of the way we
have um
you know i'm mostly gonna skip a lot of
this if you're watching on youtube go
ahead and check us out on odyssey where
the chat is live
uh
find some of our cool merchandise at
www.darkstoredarkcoursestore.org
home
that's darkhorsestore.org
is where you can find some really cool
stuff like epic tabby tote bags and
pfizer where the breakthroughs never
stop in youtube community guidelines
because you can't handle the truth
all this and more at
thedarkhorsestore.org
check out my weekly writings at
naturalselections.substance.com
and as a reminder we are supported by
you and we appreciate you we appreciate
you subscribing to this channel
weinstein to our clips channel uh if
you're looking for shorter if if we do
something that you like that feels like
it could have been done in a shorter
form
um and not not as part of the whole
podcast there's a good chance that our
awesome clips producer has clipped it
and put it on the dark horse podcast
clips channel um
and we have those at both uh youtube and
odyssey you clearly want to say
something yeah uh one more plug um
michael schellenberg we're
so right now we're talking about ways
that we are appreciative of our audience
and how they can support us and how they
are supporting us right in my defense i
am appreciative of michael
schallenberger
yeah okay go on
all right
um podcast out this week with me
interviewing no i don't interview i have
discussions with i had a discussion with
michael schellenberger and as with the
discussion that i had uh that we put out
the prior week with matthias desmond
there's a good bit of disagreement
friendly disagreement good nature
disagreement but pointed
uh substantive disagreement and so if
you're interested in hearing how these
things get hashed out by
adults who care deeply about what
they're talking about this is another
good example of that
i would say the
constantine kissing episode also had
that feature so anyway check out the
michael shellenberger episode of the
dark horse podcast it's a long one i was
on the road doing my own recording and
we did have a uh
a
camera drop out at the end so the
video quality changes in the last few
minutes of the podcast but it's all
there and it's a good discussion
all right all right so back to thanking
our audience right um so that discussion
is presumably uh everywhere that these
live streams go which is to say uh on
youtube on odyssey ultimately on spotify
and then also in audio form um
everywhere everywhere that podcasts are
available
and um just a reminder youtube
demonetized us about a year ago now
and so for those of you who are able to
we are grateful very grateful for your
financial support
you can join one of our patreons
where we have monthly private q and a's
where it is small enough that that we
can actually engage with the chat as
it's happening and we leave those up for
patrons afterwards to listen to
and you can get access to
small real-time conversations with brett
at his at a larger
dollar amount and either of them you can
access our discord server where you can
engage in honest conversations about
difficult topics join a book club unwind
with virtual happy hours and karaoke
and they've got the you know all the
demographic markers you can imagine
are are represented on all parts of this
those spectrums which is which is
terrific because that's what
conversations
um should include
um and of course we have sponsors so
let's jump right to that we have um
we only accept sponsors um
we only run ads for sponsors with whom
we have uh an actual positive
relationship either us directly or in
some cases as in the case of the third
sponsor today if we don't have any
ability to have a relationship with the
sponsor we ask a good friend who does
you mean relationship with the product
we are vouching for the product and then
the cases where we do not use the
product because we don't have a need for
it we ask trusted people
can evaluate it so the first
the first sponsor this week is thesis
new to us this summer and we are excited
to be partnering with them thesis makes
no tropics no tropics are nutrients
found in nature or in the human body
that have been demonstrated to enhance
mental performance in areas such as
motivation creativity mood memory focus
or cognitive processing they work best
when combined with exercise proper
nutrition and mindfulness activity such
as meditation as does so much in life
you're probably already using anatropic
as one of the most commonly consumed
ones is caffeine but it's far from the
least from the most exciting or the
least i suppose
effective notropics allow people to
optimize their focus energy and mood
based on the demands of the day in some
cases no tropics can replace the
pharmaceuticals that are usually used to
tackle a problem like adhd
thesis is unusual in the nootropic
market and taking a very personalized
approach they do not assume that what
works for your brother will work for you
or that what worked for you when you
were under deadline for a dreadful
project will be the same thing that will
work when you need a spark of creativity
for a project you've been dreaming about
for years just as some people become
alert after a cup of coffee and others
can fall asleep right away so too do all
nootropics have different effects on
different people
with the first iteration of thesis
products customers were treated like
subjects in a clinical trial blinded
customers took a series of different
nootropic blends over the course of a
month and reported how they felt
analysis of that feedback found that not
surprisingly different people respond
differently to different blends now
after two years 2500 customers and
millions of data points thesis is
competent that they have created a
recommendation algorithm to predict
which blends of no tropics will work
best for any given customer
the process is simple go to their
website take a short quiz and they'll
send a starter kit with four different
blend recommendations to try over the
course of a month i have tried four
blends now all have been intriguing the
creativity blend for instance seems to
smooth things over add a little clarity
and make inspiration come a bit easier
and the logic blend seems to facilitate
focus and getting lots of tasks done
with fully personalizable blends there
is likely to be a thesis that is right
for you
to get your own customized thesis
starter kit go online to takethesis.com
darkhorse take the quiz and use code
darkhorse at checkout for 10 off of your
first box yeah i love their scientific
approach to figuring out what no tropics
are going to work for you yes a breath
of fresh air indeed indeed indeed
our second sponsor this month no today
i've got all sorts of typos in this
script um our first
our second sponsor today
uh is also relatively new to us element
that's lmnt
element is an electrolyte drink mix that
has everything you need and nothing you
don't it's got a lot of salts 1000
milligrams of sodium 200 milligrams of
potassium and 60 of magnesium but it has
no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten no fillers
electrolytes facilitate hundreds of
functions in the body including the
conduction of nerve impulses hormonal
regulation and nutrient absorption
element can help prevent and eliminate
headaches muscle cramps and
sleeplessness
i've now heard from several friends
independently of one another about how
much they like element for themselves or
in some cases for the physically
hard-working men in their lives they
drink it every day and feel better doing
so
when you set set wow when you sweat
the primary electrolyte lost is sodium
athletes can lose up to seven grams per
day element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and is
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet if that's
your thing
element is not just for athletes though
anyone being active may find that they
benefit from element even drinking a few
glasses of wine can leave you depleted
an element can help right now element is
offering our listeners a free sample
pack with any purchase that's eight
single serving packets free with any
element order this is a great way to try
all eight flavors or share element with
a salty friend
or a friend who's not yet salty
get yours at drinkelement.com
horse this deal is only available
through our drink
no wow this deal is only available
through our link
you must go to
drinkelement.com
darkhorse that's d-r-i-n-k
dot com slash dark horse element offers
no questions and
this doesn't even look like english my
god
element offers no questions asked
refunds try it totally risk-free if you
don't like it share it with a salty
friend or again a friend who's not salty
enough yet and they will give you your
money back no questions asked you have
nothing to lose oh man well
so i think i got it though um
i really do like the stuff yeah just
can't read a script today how about this
potential slogan without electrolytes
consciousness itself would be impossible
right and i don't think doubt can touch
you i don't think doubt can touch you i
mean
they've
got some noodly appendages yeah it's
it's satire i think a slogan that is
satire is protected 16 ways from sunday
yeah
i've never understood that expression
but um i don't know how many ways you
can get out of sunday in my experience
it's one it's linear one right through
sunday the only way out of sunday is
through yeah um all right our final
sponsor this week is empty hearing aid
empty hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford recognizing that
about 95 percent of the people who need
a hearing aid only require a few
settings he removed some of the less
often needed components he also cut out
the middleman and now md hearing aid
makes a rechargeable hearing aid that is
fda registered and costs a small
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus is water
resistant in up to three feet of water
and you don't need a prescription to get
one you buy it directly from the source
where audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists are available seven days a
week everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation and others are that others
are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and this is what
she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech i wore md hearing aid
i wore the md hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced man in a
room with a lot of white noise the md
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable
at a price point under a thousand
dollars i was amazed at how effective
they are
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with 100 money-back
guarantee get clinic level care for 80
less with md hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids costs
just
149.99 plus darkhorse listeners receive
a free extra charging case a hundred
dollar value so head to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal of hearing aids
149 bucks 149.99 for the pair
all right i almost got through reading
that one you did probably much better
than i did
[Music]
true
do you want to start or should i start
today um you go ahead i go ahead okay
since i'm off to such a fun well i don't
know
yeah it could be a music it could be
amusing indeed okay here we are i i'm
just going to keep an eye on the time
because we do have to be kind of
kind of kind of fast and furious today
snappy yeah but we will be back next
week uh when presumably we'll have a
little bit more time a little bit more
relaxed we don't know
we hope we hope yes if the future is
anything like the past which so far it
hasn't really been so i don't know
um
in some ways it is physically speaking
the laws change
very little as far as i can tell the the
physical it's a colossal
okay
um
yeah let's start with um this nature
news article
uh zach if you want to show my screen so
nature of course is one of the two
major uh the the two premier science
journals in the world science uh which
is published in the us being the other
one nature comes out of great britain
and uh they have not only sort of what
is deemed to be the most elite
uh original the primary literature that
is published uh across all of the
domains of science but they also have a
news division where they report
on scientific findings that have not
been published in nature itself so this
is a nature news article
published this week called prior omicron
infection protects against ba i actually
don't know if how you pronounce this
ba.4 and ba.5 variants i haven't heard
it pronounced i haven't either i've only
been reading it
um so again the headline prior omicron
infection protects against ba.4 and b8.5
variants catching an earlier version of
series cov2 particularly omicron
provides some immunity against the two
fast spreading lineages okay if i may
have my screen back zach
thank you
um
i want to say a few a number of things
here and rather than
simply dissect the nature news article
we're going to go to the pre-prints that
they are that they are referring to
and that's one of one of the points i
want to make that
now apparently
when the news suits nature we are
allowed to talk about the science
reported in pre-prince as we were early
in the days of covid
but for a while there we were being told
that if it hadn't been peer reviewed
then it wasn't really science and uh we
weren't really supposed to be uh
referring to that as a scientific result
that is that is
fascinating and it is a major concession
in many ways without
that's that's one of the sort of three
main things that i noticed about this
and you know again i'll link to the
article in the show notes um but the
entire article is referring to mostly
one but also a second
uh preprints
which
are exactly the style of papers that
most of us have have been having to rely
on almost exclusively throughout covid
in order to figure out what is going on
in part because early on the rate of
research was so fast and furious that
the journals couldn't keep up and then
at some point of course you started to
get
you know censorship within the journals
wherein
non-acceptable non you know mainstream
conclusions weren't being published and
so peer review became a mechanism of
censorship but now we have two
pre-prints being discussed in nature
news yeah i just want to say um i'm
going to try to remember this actually
dovetails with something i plan to talk
about later in our discussion
uh it's a third example of something for
which i had two
um
so anyway
uh i've made a note to myself but if you
hear it come up in line and i fail to
mention it
i mean if you want to talk about it now
you can't no no i i want to wait so that
you have the other two and you can see
uh the pattern okay
uh so that's that's one point about this
article um another is and you know no
doubt everyone has noticed that for a
while we were getting new variant names
you know every time i don't every time
what was i how would how would i even
finish that sentence right we were
getting new variant names and then
omicron shows up depending on where you
are in the world to end in 2021
and
we're still in omicron but now we're
getting new like sub-variant names and
this feels like the kind of game that
systematists play systematists being the
type of scientists who are
biologists who are evolutionary
biologists who are phylogeneticists who
are systematists
those type of evolutionary biologists
being those who are trying to determine
the relationships between species or in
this case
viral variants
and you know what point that you you
decide oh that's actually a species
versus a subspecies in the case of an
organism rather than a virus
is a judgment call but this change from
we're getting new variants to we're
getting new for you know some
sub-variants of omicron
feels also like it was political rather
than
scientific and there's no discussion as
far as i see as to you know no
justification as to why that is the case
so i want to point out
it it is beyond a judgment call
it is arbitrary unless somebody has set
out a standard against which you would
have to make a judgment call in other
words you could say here you need a
certain number of
substantive changes to the code before
you call it uh a new variant versus a
sub variant or something but absence
which is exactly that's the kind of rule
that you could use for viral variants
you couldn't use that for species
because we don't we don't have them
sequenced at that level right and in
biology
in most disciplines which do not focus
on phylogenetics but have to interface
with it as most of the disciplines in
biology do
there is not an awareness of how little
meaning
is contained in the level of distinction
right the fact that things are a clade
is meaningful but the fact that we call
it a family versus a sub family or you
know a genus versus uh
uh a subgenus
is is meaningless some of us eschew
categorical rank well yeah we joke in
our household that we issue categorical
rank because our category being family
genus those right
order we do not at all issue the
description of the clades that is to say
who is related to whom is a factual
question you can get it right you can
get it wrong but there is nothing
arbitrary about it right two creatures
are more closely related to each other
than either are to a third right that's
a factual description there's no
judgment call there um it's just a
question of what the evidence suggests
the relationship is and we may have it
wrong but the history is the history
right the history is whatever the
history is even if we never figure out
what it is so
amongst those of us who take
phylogenetic systematics very very
seriously at a logical level
you know heather and i for example if we
are having a dinner table conversation
and somebody says i don't remember you
know is a skunk a weasel is it a
stellate right
the answer is
it doesn't really matter because skunks
mind i'm remembering we should have done
this with a tree we should prepare it
for that i should have looked this up
see whether this is still the evidence
but the evidence is although skunks are
not classified within the mustelity
currently they are the group right
outside of it which means that you could
have just as easily made the group one
rung larger and it would include them
and so the point is it's somebody's
arbitrary judgments happen to be put
into something called the mephistids i
think and then we got the mustelids
which is all the weasels right but if if
the mustelids the weasels plus the
skunks is a group that doesn't exclude
anybody then the point is
well we don't have to
uh have a discussion about whether
they're technically in the most healthy
we know what the relationship is and so
what you're pointing out with respect to
these variants
is that i mean maybe there is some
standard somewhere and we will hear
about it um or maybe there isn't a
standard as is true in so many quadrants
of biology and the basic point maybe
new variants were beginning to grow old
and so people you know they didn't want
to have to learn
how to speak about a new variant so
they've downgraded the level of
evolutionary difference
in you know in uh
in the at the
level of parlance or worse um you know
the the propagation of new variants was
making people question the efficacy of
the public health policies that were in
place which you know largely
mass vaccination
right right and so really the question i
would argue
there's a natural place that you could
draw this distinction which is natural
immunity right in other words
oh it is all right well no i mean well
my point would be i would say
you are
meaningfully dealing with a new variant
at the point that the immunity that you
got to your prior variant uh fails to
prevent you from getting the new one
okay so let's just finish talking about
the variance here but then this this is
interesting because this does tie
together you know we haven't we didn't
talk about what i was going to yeah we
the you you the you would only got it
you and i uh did not discuss in advance
what i wanted to say here but uh i think
that will you'll see that that fits
together very nicely um let's
just see what the cdc has to say about
variants though shall we um zach you may
show my screen
this is um
yeah cdc page you can see at the top
there sars kobe 2 variant
classifications and definitions
uh and you know there's a lot of you
know key definitions mutation
recombinant lineage variant key points
and i'm going to if i may have my screen
back for a moment just go to my pdf
zack
thank you
so that
i can
um
here we go
uh
okay so this is the same document you
can see this is just a pdf version of
that same document
um
they are talking about here key points
with regard to variants of series cov2
in their document they say
vaccines approved and authorized for use
in the united states are effective
against the predominant variant
circulating in the united states and
effective therapeutics are available
really
that seems
like quite a general statement for which
there is no evidence offered
and it's not hot linked unlike a lot of
the things they've got here and then if
you go down further and find that um all
of these there's all these variants
being monitored alpha beta gamma delta
epsilon eta iota kappa zeta mu who knew
who knew and uh
and what we have under variance of
concern is
omicron okay omicron is the only variant
of concern at the moment but it's got
all these different lineages
attributes of omicron as the variant of
concern include
potential reduction in neutralization by
post-vaccination sera
which strikes me as rather directly in
conflict to the earlier claim in this
very same document
that uh what we've got in the form of
vaccines is exactly what you need for
the dominant strain which omicron is so
within a single document this took
nothing this took nothing just like cdc
variants what do they have to say huh
within one document they contradict
themselves and they do it without even
pretending to be referring to any actual
evidence they just are making claims
um
and i don't know hoping that no one
notices which so far very few people
seem to be noticing at least if they
have a voice in the public square you
know every so often there's a story of
somebody who has faked their way into
some profession and you know as behaving
as a surgeon or something without ever
having studied the discipline
right
they usually make a point of doing
better than the cdc does at being a
public health authority yeah it's really
remarkable how badly the cdc does at
this job and even i mean if we
understood the cdc to be simply a pr
organization at this point which we've
said this before and it's been a while
since we've talked about this but
when back when we were in grad school
before every trip and indeed back when i
was running study abroad trips i would
be on the phone with the cdc in advance
trying to figure out exactly you know
why the recommendations for the
particular vaccinations were for where
we were because different part you know
it doesn't make sense to have for
instance an ecuador-wide or a madagascar
wide vaccination recommendation because
frankly the lo you know the jungles the
lowland tropical forests on the coast
are going to have very different
diseases with very different vectoring
insects than you're going to have at
elevation where it gets to freezing or
below freezing at night right it's just
not going to be the same the same
illnesses so
i
have had in the past several very
compelling conversations with the
tropical disease people at the cdc uh
and
that is part of why i find myself
feeling almost
repeat i mean i'm over it at this point
because i no longer take them seriously
i don't know who could but it feels like
something happened to this agency
because it used to actually at least
have some number of people well
it is
it is an exact mirror of
what i always say about the effect of
the clinton administration on the
democratic party that the clinton
administration is the point at which the
democratic party abandoned
working people and representing working
people whether you're cynical about it
or not is a go-to winning strategy in a
democracy but
what the democratic party did under
clinton was it embraced the same kind of
corruption that the republicans were so
good at and so the point is it needs to
pretend to care about people now but it
has real constituents right people who
pay up and the cdc has made the same
transition it has gone
from serving people who wish not to get
sick
to uh serving um
let's just say an industry with very
special product placement needs
right they uh they're excellent at
getting a product placed like for
example in uh millions of arms yeah you
know yes yeah yes oh that's that's
exactly right
okay so um point three about this nature
news article which comes comes back
around to
something that you were you were
alluding to here is a reminder that and
don't show my screen here yet zach that
the title of the nature news article is
prior omicron infection protects against
ba.4 and ba.5 variants
and uh and indeed what that entire
nature news article suggests is
precisely that that omicron having been
infected with omicron protects against
omicron but having been protected
um having been infected with some a
variant that wasn't omicron doesn't
provide you uh much protection
but when you actually go to the research
as i did and i you know i did not do the
research i did not spend as much time as
i could with these papers
but uh the original research
doesn't say what it says it says as is
too often the case so let us go to
this is the alterane paper there's a
couple of papers here
um
this one and that's you can show my
screen here and again i'll link to the
the version of this is on the web but
i've got a pdf here
this is this the pre-print that is
primarily being uh referred to in this
nature news article uh and the second
author is the primary author on the
other preprint so this is a team out of
cutter
and they have looked at um at infections
and basically health records in cutter
that's how it's pronounced right never
never strikes me as right
uh which uh apparently you know is a
very unusual usual place uh with
something like gosh i forgot now but um
like closing in on ninety percent of the
people aren't from there and only less
than ten percent of the people are over
fifty uh so it's you know
demographically very diverse in one way
but doesn't have very many old people
so the title of this paper this preprint
uh
which is the basis on which nature news
said omicron previous infection with
omicron provides immunity against future
infection with omicron a previous
infection with non-elemicron doesn't do
you as much good
the title is protection of sars kovi to
natural infection against reinfection
with the omicron b8.4b5 sub variants
okay i'm going to scroll sorry make you
make you guys dizzy a little bit here
um and in there this is what this is in
this the abstract protection they say
protection of a previous infection
against ba4 ba 5 reinfection was modest
when the previous infection involved a
pre-omicron variant
but strong when the previous infection
involved the omicron ba.1 or b8.2
sub-variants so that seems to be
consistent with what you were arguing
what we might expect like we we might
expect that if there really are distinct
differences between between say omicron
and delta and the differences between
omicron and delta are greater than the
differences between omicron ba1 and
omicron ba5
that the natural immunity that
an infection would confer would be
greater
the the more closely related
the the infectious agents were to one
another you would expect that
but what did they do to assess this and
sorry again scrolling scrolling
scrolling
this is in the methods
previous infections were classified as
pre-omicron versus omicron previous
infections based on whether they
occurred before or after the omicron
wave that started in qatar in december
19 2021
literally the only thing they did was
said if you were infected before
december 19th it must not have been
omicron if we were infected after
december 19th it must be emicron
there were two obvious problems with
this
aside from no they didn't actually test
for whether or not omicron was
conferring a natural immunity advantage
against omicron they they did not do
that
one of the issues is of course we don't
we don't actually know
what people were infected with although
presumably omicron wasn't
circulating in say december 2020
presumably but do we really know that
more to the point though what we
actually have here is a time stamp i
mean quite literally this is a time
stamp and so what they have found is the
totally obvious but apparently from you
know if you were listening to the who
and the cdc for the last couple years
maybe they didn't quite track this
thing that we know from every other
immune response ever which is that the
more recently you've been exposed to the
pathogen the more likely you are to
maintain natural immunity to that
pathogen
right if
so all we know in fact from this
research is the more recent
your exposure to covid the more likely
you are to maintain natural immunity to
cope well i mean it i mean maybe i'm
missing something here but it just seems
especially in light of the fact that the
entire reason we're talking about
variants is that this thing is evolving
in real time right
how can you do this and just simply say
after this date it is x variant
this is exactly the thing that you would
need to check in order to know whether
or not you were
seeing phenomenon a or phenomenon b
are you seeing escape from
natural immunity or are you seeing
incompleteness of natural immunity
they're two distinct things and there's
no way to tell from this research and
what the editorial staff at nature again
one of the two premier science journals
in the entire world did was
take the abstract at face value and not
and again i didn't spend a ton of time
with this paper it didn't take much and
indeed nature news article does have two
virologists
say yeah it's good work but there is
this problem it's like well i don't
think that qualifies as good work then
so one one more thing go on well i just
want to point out there's something i
mean i think the most important thing
here is
the way
nature is dealing with the world of
pre-prince nature the magazine not
nature the
no no not nature the phenomenon nature
well i guess nature of the magazine is a
phenomenon but um
but nonetheless the
we are told
that what makes it science is peer
review which is of course total garbage
right what makes it science is the
freaking method right that's what makes
it science peers to the extent that they
can do something they can evaluate
whether or not the method was done
correctly and whether or not the things
that you believe follow from
your evidence actually do follow from it
that is not inherent to peer review
review by peers does it also but there's
something fascinating about this
nature so first of all you probably in
the audience will not know unless you're
a professional scientist
that the people who staff these journals
the top flight journals that make and
break careers right these people are
people who often did not succeed in
science itself right in other words they
have effectively left
the rat race of academia and joined the
rat race of the journals which is a
different game right so i don't want to
call them failed academics but in some
ways that's that's partially what it is
but the point is okay these are the
stewards of this magical process we call
peer review right these are the
peer-to-peers
look at what they do with an
unpeer-reviewed article first they
grudgingly start looking at this stuff
which they should have now what you and
i have said about the pre-print
literature non-peer-reviewed literature
is that it's very noisy right the
quality varies a lot that's natural
because it hasn't been through a filter
in which people will catch errors that
said it is less distorted by the peer
review process so it's not obvious that
more noise is inherently bad if it comes
with also more signal because
inconvenient truths haven't been
excluded for example right so there is
value in that preprint literature
precisely because it hasn't been put
through our corrupt system what happens
when our corrupt system touches it with
the evaluation by peers in this case the
people who write nature news they get it
wrong right they reveal not only there's
value in the
uh
so-called non-peer-reviewed literature
but that when peers touch it there's
nothing magical about their evaluation
they can botch it they do the same thing
scientists do when they're in a rush
which is they you know assume that what
is reported in the title and the
abstract is actually what is uh
suggested by the paper so anyway the the
whole thing is kind of revealing itself
it is and um
it's uh
it's it's a pity you have to know where
the bodies are buried in order to see
what's being acknowledged and what's
being botched um because really
everybody needs to be
uh
exposed to
the evidence that peer review is not a
magical process it's a corrupt process
and it's a flawed process even even when
it works it's a deeply flawed process
and it is so corrupt as to be
counterproductive in many contexts
indeed
so just a couple more things on um
on this here and zach you may show my
screen if you'd like is the other
preprint
referred to in that nature news article
this is
uh this has as the first author who was
the the guy that was the second author i
think it's a guy
uh from that other paper
and it is titled duration of immune
protection of sars kobe 2 natural
infection against reinfection and cutter
and this uh this i assessed actually
less completely than i did the first
article and so i'm not going to make
claims as to
as to how well done this particular
research was it's a lot it's a lot more
sticky with regard to the statistics
that they use but here is a
line from i think it's the discussion
this is just my pdf version of that same
article
this waning in natural immunity mirrors
that of vaccine immunity
but at a slower rate
vaccine immunity may last for only a
year but natural immunity assuming
gompert's decay may last for three years
so
this is one of the first times if not
the first time that i've seen an
acknowledgement
of natural immunity being superior to
vaccine-induced immunity in the
scientific literature
there
i believe it has been described it is
very contentious and not widely accepted
but i believe it's been described
elsewhere
i'm struggling with whether or not
they're conflating two things
right there
vaccine immunity
should be expected to wane because it's
crappy immunity right even to the extent
that we talk about it in terms of
antibodies they're not the core of a
robust
immune response they're easily measured
and that's why we focus on them
they're easily measured and frankly to
the extent that you want to manipulate
the public the public has some idea what
an antibody is or at least that they're
important and they don't really know
what a t cell is so um so the point is
we've focused on them but it's it's a
feeble kind of immunity
and therefore
you might expect that because the immune
system does not depend on this typically
for uh
for immunity to viruses to which you've
been exposed that the short-lived
antibody response might wane rapidly and
to the extent that vaccine manufacturers
tap into the antibody response as their
mechanism for preventing disease that it
would wane rapidly because it doesn't
have
the proper characteristics for
long-term durable immunity that's one
phenomenon the failure of the immunity
that was generated by the experience if
you got sick your immunity was more
durable than if you got vaccinated okay
but the other thing
um has to do with the evolution of the
pathogen right right and so the the
you know this team was
looked like they were trying to sort
that out in the first paper i was
talking about but then when you look at
their methods you find that they
actually just used a date you know a
moment in time before and after which
was their proxy for variants which is
which is
not acceptable it's not evidence yes yes
it is assumption it's the problem it's
it is an assumption masquerading as
evidence right and that's a no no that's
a big one yeah um but so i don't know i
don't know what to do with the fact that
you've got these two you know to say
that the immunity wanes
may even be technically true but is it
you know you could get that if you had
perfectly static levels of antibody
immunity and the pathogen evolved away
so that they were less and less
well-tuned that would cause the observed
phenomenon of less and less uh
effectiveness so is part of what you're
going after here is you know what
what does immunity wanes mean you have
um antibody versus t cell but let's put
that aside for the moment
for the moment you also have
has your immunity to the thing you were
exposed to waned or has the thing you
were exposed to becomes so
such a minority representative in the
population of this broad lineage of
viruses
such that while that original immunity
that you got from an older lineage uh
may still help a little bit with
anything you would be exposed to in
modern times
it's not that your immune system
um forgot what it knew it's that it is
now being exposed to something that
didn't exist before not only that and
this i think is
where the rubber meets the road for a
lot of this
there is a question that haunts our
entire coveted response
would we be better off if we had done
nothing
right now that's not the only question
we had other things to do that were not
these
vaccines
right but had we done nothing would we
be better off today than we are today
given what we did in which case you
don't want to do the kind of thing we
did right now i don't think we can
answer that question i think
i have a strong suspicion but the basic
point is if you if your
stupid
narrowly targeted vaccine-like substance
that you have
transfected people with if that thing
is simply pushing around an evolutionary
ninja right right if you have come at
like a ninja with
plastic cutlery right and the ninja is
right exactly if that's what we're doing
right and the point is you know we are
training the ninja what we can see by
coming at it with a plastic knife that
can't possibly work and right
it's just a mistake and i mean that you
actually then arrive us at what was what
was going to be my final point here um
well
which is
how dare they why are we in this
position at all like we're not i'm not
talking about vaccines at this point i'm
talking about you know
who gave anyone the right to create this
ninja in the first place
right okay
what if we had done nothing
in march 2020 when this thing had
emerged how about what if we had done
nothing in march 2010 i'm making that
number up i have no idea when gain of
function research was in its early
nascent stages and some people thought
it was really great and we're putting
together lots of justifications because
that's what you need to do and they
started to buy their own press and they
started to create these things which
have escaped from their damn bottles and
there's no putting this genie back in no
there's just there's there's the bottle
is gone the genie is out here we're all
stuck with it and now they're just
adding
you know
injury to injury yeah injury to injury
is right yeah there's
to the extent that it has become quite
clear that this
came from the lab and even in the tiny
remaining chance that it did not that it
certainly could have right
if if this didn't if this came from the
wet market the fact that there was a
laboratory whatever it is 14 kilometers
away uh turbocharging exactly the sort
of virus without the ability to prevent
a leak means is it gonna be the ferret
badger popsicles again
yeah ferret badger popsicles uh again is
is right but to the extent that we did
everything necessary to create this
insane condition and probably did create
this insane condition right this should
be a
a an absolute focus and yet
we
so many of us are aware but the usual
process by which the public becoming
aware that something terrible and
needless has to fall in it right would
usually trigger a response that we just
don't see we just don't and actually
here's one more thing and then i'll then
i'll stand down
um
into this landscape
find uh this so you
may if you like show my screen here it's
a little bit small
zach um
this is the
attorney general from missouri site uh
zach you gonna show my screen or not
okay cool
uh
this this piece is dated from may
but there is a new development this week
the title just reads missouri and
louisiana attorneys general file suit
against president biden and top admin
officials for allegedly colluding with
social media giants to censor and
suppress free speech
and here we have attorney general
schmidt that's the attorney general in
missouri saying
and it's
here what i've got highlighted for those
of you watching in the lawsuit that
missouri and louisiana filed today again
this was back in may
we allege that government officials in
the biden administration including
president biden press secretary jen
pasaki back in the days dr anthony fauci
surgeon general vivek murthy and others
cluded with social media companies like
meta twitter and youtube to remove
truthful information relating to the lab
leak theory the efficacy of masks
election integrity and more and
they also say down here
that they have named also director of
the department of homeland security's
disinformation governance board nina
jankowitz which of course the
disinformation board has since been
disbanded on the basis that i guess it
was all too clear that what they were
engaging in was disinformation
themselves
but here we have two of the 50 attorneys
general in the united states saying you
know what we there's enough
and let's see it'll be interesting to
see what happens
yeah interesting so a judge said that uh
discovery can happen discovery yeah boy
um this is obviously
that sword there sticking through the uh
the countertop that is the uh the
metaphorical sword of damocles which
hang it still above the dark horse we
having been demonetized and uh us
feeling the thumb on the scales that
google applies when it is not pleased
with the things that we discuss with our
audience
in any case so this has tremendous
import i very much look forward to
hearing what discovery on earth's it
will no doubt be fascinating indeed
all right all right sir i think i am
going to reverse
the order of my plan in light of where
you started so hey zach you want to give
thank you
um so
i want to talk briefly about a piece in
newsweek of all places
um newsweek which still exists
at least online
uh anyway they published something by
jeremy lee quinn who has been a guest of
dark horse twice i believe jeremy lee
quinn is a very interesting fellow he is
a journalist a freelance journalist
who was on the ground on january 6th in
washington he's been on the ground here
in portland he was on the ground for
riots in la he does seem to know where
to go to see
violence unfolding in any case he
published a piece that do you want to
put up uh the
piece in question
there it is all right so this is a piece
um
jeremy lee quinn january 6 followed
years of political violence the
committee should investigate leftist
violence 2.
now
oh
so
the reason i raise this is is
actually two different reasons okay one
jeremy lee quinn is not a right winger
in fact
he considers himself an anarchist and at
some point i'd like to have a
conversation with him about what that
really means i uh understand him to be a
very reasonable guy and it's hard for me
to imagine how any very reasonable
person becomes an anarchist but he seems
to take
a decidedly
nuanced approach to anarchism and i'd
like to understand what the nature of it
is so stay tuned for that at some point
we'll do it but i think you talked a
little bit about it in
what you did we did let's just say i
still don't quite get it and so i have a
feeling that you know he's technically
an anarchist but doesn't
doesn't mean what most of us infer from
that but nonetheless
the piece that he writes essentially
says look january 6 was a travesty but
it exists in a context of political
violence stretching back years on both
sides and it is impossible i think to
read this piece and not realize what's
going on i have not been paying
attention to the january 6 committee
because i know it to be theater and i
know i can't afford to grind my teeth as
much as i surely would if i um was
tuning in
but what little i have seen and gleaned
does suggest that what's going on here
is an obsessive focus on the excesses of
one side and a
studied disinterest what eric calls
anti-interest in the political violence
on the other side and the problem is you
can't understand what january 6th was
until you realize that it was basically
part of a tit for tat exchange that
stretches back you know a couple of
years as i said before so before anyone
gets their panties on a wad here you are
not justifying anything you are
explaining that this does not exist in a
vacuum and that
we as a country seem to be um
explicitly avoiding discussion of some
types of political violence and not
others
right but
really what i'm saying is that the crime
is the committee that is
inherently only interested in one kind
of political violence to the extent that
these people want to pretend to be
serious patriots investigating a threat
to the country the threat to the country
is the process that generates this kind
of reaction right it's not one side's
version of it and the other side's
version of it is just fine that's
[ __ ] right so
i would invite everyone to read the
article which we will link in the
description
and to just see all of the
cases that jeremy lee quinn puts forward
and understand this committee as a
it's basically
treason biomission right by highlighting
one side's successes exaggerating them
where possible
and ignoring the excesses of the other
side which are every bit as egregious
it is creating a picture about who is a
threat to the country when in fact the
uh
the lopsidedness the double standard is
the threat right understanding that we
have come to a place where we've lost
the ability to understand each other we
see the other side as a threat to the
country and we you know uh
we see
there being no excess in the challenge
to that kind of threat blah blah blah
blah blah it's nonsense as long as it's
one-sided so
okay the reason i have come back here
is that increasingly
all of the issues that we discuss are
about double standards and the way they
are being weaponized right now
alexandros morenos has uh begun to
follow this thread uh quite deliberately
i think it's incredibly important
but i wanted to
now i have three examples
um i had two when i started i mentioned
i think it was last week maybe it was
the week before
that we ought to expect in the context
of
academic medicine in the context of
medical science we ought to expect an
increasing discrepancy between efficacy
that is to say how good things look
under laboratory conditions and
effectiveness what they do in the real
world that gap ought to grow the more
corrupt the laboratory environment is
now it's not a perfect comparison
addiction
is that with increasing corruption
efficacy effectiveness
will
cease to track one another closely right
now the problem with that which i freely
acknowledge is that effectiveness is
also academically measured so
right if your vaccines show an efficacy
of 98
and then in the real world they clearly
don't work that well but you still may
exaggerate how well they do work right
so efficacy and effectiveness will not
depart as much as you would expect them
to but they will still depart and so
that should be awful because there may
be a problem in the measurement not
because there may be a problem in the
actual reality right right the re yeah
the prediction
holds regardless but whether or not we
will have access to
good data is
is not a guarantee let's put it this way
the reason that we have laboratories is
for something that we rightly call
control
right you can exclude
random noisy phenomena that would
interfere with your ability to measure a
pattern uninvited monkeys for instance
uninvited monkeys uh you know perkins
the effect of the weather all of these
things are excluded by a laboratory so
control is a good thing scientifically
speaking but it has come to mean
something else i'm afraid which is the
ability to control the story the ability
to make the data set reflect something
that it in fact shouldn't reflect and
the point is that's harder to do in the
real world so the departure between uh
efficacy which is the laboratory version
and effectiveness which is the
uh outer world version
uh is an indicator that something
corrupt is afoot
similarly i would argue there is a gap
between
climate models
and what i would call integrative
measures phenomena that integrate the
and mind you
i believe
we have reason to be quite frightened
about climate change and that reason
anthropogenic climate change the reason
that i believe that we should be quite
frightened about it is that the
methane clathrates which are frozen in
uh in the arctic
are potentially
at some threshold point
able to take the question of the
temperature of planet earth completely
out of human hands and basically
the
possibility of a positive feedback
causing temperature to run away is there
right how close we are i really couldn't
tell you
but
what what i'm arguing is that as the
field becomes
intolerant of heterodox perspectives on
climate right in other words let's say
global warming is real right but it's a
complex phenomenon some papers will
reflect it's not as bad as we feared
some papers will say oh it's worse than
we feared that's what you would expect
in a healthy environment but what if
politically
the environment inside academia is
unwilling to tolerate anybody who comes
up with a result that is not alarmist
right because the whole point is well we
need people alarmed so they'll act so
you can't publish anything that goes in
the other direction right that's clearly
where we are so what would you expect to
to see if that were the case if there
was
anthropogenic climate change but the
environment was intolerant of dealing
with the give and take that would be
involved in understanding how bad it is
and how quickly it is occurring right
well you would expect a departure
between models
and empirical phenomena it's the
efficacy versus effectiveness again and
so here's what i've been saying for some
time is that
i do believe that there is anthropogenic
climate change
and the reason that i believe it is
because i have seen
things like glacial retreat right that
said the models tell me and have told me
repeatedly the arctic should have been
ice free by now right and it never is
right and the snows of kilimanjaro
should be a thing of the past they
should be
uh effectively a historical artifact
they're not gone the glaciers have
retreated but they're not gone i was
told the glacier national park was going
to be ironically named because there'd
be no glaciers left in it that's not
true
um and so anyway my point is you can't
spin a glacier into retreating glaciers
don't care what we think or say right
they simply respond to
things like albedo and
you know
[Music]
actual weather phenomena
so you would expect in a in a case where
the field was corrupt you would expect
the models to be alarmist and you would
expect the glaciers to be less alarmist
right and that is in fact what we see
now again i'm not telling you that i
don't think we should be very concerned
and proactive about global warming i do
think so why because if we cross that
threshold in the arctic then this is
going to become an academic question in
which
we don't know how many people a
world following that positive feedback
can support or what quality of life they
will have but it's not something that we
would rationally risk
right we have a world that functions
well
right to disrupt it in the hope that it
will function well on the other side of
such a thing is the height of folly and
so anyway
uh
your third example my third example is
the double standard involved in the
january 6
hearings and all of the things that look
like it right in an environment so a the
departure between
the
um actual pattern of let's say political
violence that which is to say it's
coming from both sides and it is
increasingly common
and the portrayal which is entirely
one-sided that gap
measures the same thing right the point
is it is a measure of the corruption of
the entities and in effect
um well if we go back to what i said
about the clinton administration again
the way these parties function now is
they have real constituents that is to
say the people who
pay right they have these are industries
that pay for influence and then there is
the winning of influence by manipulating
enough voters to vote for them that they
actually have some power to monetize
right so that game
looks like a committee that is obsessed
with getting to the bottom of january 6
because of the threat that it poses to
the country when in fact what it's
really trying to do is whip
its voters into a frenzy so that it can
monetize the power that those voters
generate for its real constituents which
are corporations right um any country
that is uh actively trying to whip its
people into a frenzy is uh is it odds
with itself because that's an inherently
anti-patriotic act yes whipping
one fraction of the population into a
frenzy against another is a
a
true tactic for keeping people from
realizing who their actual enemies are
indeed but um but anyway that's where we
are so i'm gonna argue that those three
things are variations on a theme
hallmarks of corruption in three
different contexts
great
okay
all right where are we time-wise
uh we have
a few more minutes so you had another
thing you wanted yeah i did the question
is do i have time for it all right i'll
do it you do quickly do
um
it's a total departure from what we've
been talking about
uh last week we discussed
before you do this yeah there was a
preprint versus peer review connection
that you were gonna make oh yes yeah
thank you yeah you saved me
the pre-print versus uh
the last time i i i hope it is but only
because whatever threats there are have
receded and you no longer need to do the
job but um
anyway here's the
the point
to the extent that peer review is an
active corrupter of science
right
what you will note is a departure
between the value that is to say
preprints are inherently noisy because
the work is inherently of many different
qualities including crappy
right
so peer review gets rid of a certain
amount of crappiness there's a quality
control aspect that actually does work
right and then there's a corruption
aspect which
the question is well what's the net
effect did the work
that comes out of peer review get better
because it's less noisy or did it get
worse because it now has a bias i would
say there's actually a third thing too
so there's a um
perhaps quality control
we hope it's supposed to be about
quality control
we know that there is corruption but
there's also a standardization which i
think isn't exactly either of the first
two right where
good science can actually look a lot of
different ways and
in general scientific journals require
that you tell a story that your science
looked a particular way and if
so that either um forces people who
didn't do science that looked standard
but was good to lie about what they
actually did and thus get into the habit
of lying about what they did or that
work doesn't get published and so this
you know so good work that doesn't fit
the uh the the style really like the
guidelines for what it is that we expect
science to look like now also will tend
to end up on the i'm gonna mix my
metaphors here the cutting room floor um
with regard to not getting through peer
review and not ending up published in
journals all right so i will
rephrase it slightly i will say
peer review does many things
one of them is a perfect analog for
censorship
peers
sensor perspectives they don't like they
steal stuff they will prevent an
underling from punishing something
publishing something and then they will
publish it themselves
right that happens the joke is peer
preview right so it does many uh
different things but one of the things
that it does
is it censors views that are out of step
with whoever is powerful in the field
and
maybe most crucially knowing that your
paper has to go through peer review
causes people to self-censor it causes
them to you know probably bias their own
results it causes them to pursue things
that they think are liable you know
because an investment in a project is a
an attempt to
rise through the ranks you don't want to
write a paper even if it's a
really important paper you don't want to
write a paper that's not going to get
published because it wastes time that
you could have spent getting ahead so
people are adjusting what they do
in order to get through peer review
knowing what the biases of the peers
will will likely be especially in a
field where the biases are are intense
but anyway a i would argue
what i've seen and frankly
you know
in public people have a much better
uh
they have a much
more
they believe in peer review more than
people who've actually seen how the
process works right
the powerful people like peer review
because it's a tool that they need but
basically everybody's got stories about
what's happened to them in peer review
and how
disgusting a process it is and the
public is just not really aware of it
but so the point is
it could be that peer review falls well
short of what it's supposed to do or it
could be that it makes things actively
worse right that it's instead of a value
added it's actually a value subtracted
process which is what we saw at the
beginning of the pandemic when things
were moving too quickly for peer review
to catch up and we were all looking
directly at the preprints right was it
noisy oh you better believe it was noisy
right amazing though by wild west it was
the wild west but the point is look
that's what you train for in science you
train to get rid of noise so that you
can see signal in spite of it right
that's that's what you're supposed to be
doing and the idea that the public needs
to be protected from the noisiness of
unpeer-reviewed papers [ __ ] what
they need are people who are good at
science who are good at figuring out
what patterns are who are good at
looking at a paradox and thinking well
what what does that mean is there
something in the methods that would have
caused them to find this result that
doesn't sound like something that we
would expect right that's that's the
process and that's that's actually what
our live stream started with that's
right right we started by just
diving into this stuff that was emerging
so quickly and the fact is
it worked and not just for us right
so the point is
the
pre-print literature
has a value peer review
it's value subtracted is the point and
the gas between the value the signal
here's the thing
peer review should if it worked the way
the brochure claims it should subtract
noise and it should leave signals so you
can see it the question is how much
signal is peer review eliminating right
signal that's inconvenient for somebody
with power right whether it's a school
of thought whether it's a corporation
that funds a lot of the research in some
area the question is why is signal being
lost to peer review right and that's
really
the the damaging thing and i think it is
another one of these
gaps right oh there's signal you can see
it in the preprint literature where did
it go why is it not in the peer-reviewed
literature why did it get eliminated as
if it was noise right that's what we see
and we you know increasingly we see
crazy things like papers with important
implications that are retracted and then
you go and you look and you say well why
was it retracting it turns out the
retraction is not based on sound science
right it's
subtracting signal right yeah and you
know how you subtract it yeah that's
good uh science cannot cannot endure
that environment science is a powerful
process that is very delicate it
requires an open environment and
that is being lost
so with that i think i will postpone the
third
segment that i wanted to do for next
week
really yeah i think so okay um
yeah i guess we've been going
about an hour since uh since we got
through
the ads so um
through the end
not through the endured the uh
they were noisier the ads were noisier
today but i think the signal did get
through i did yeah
what i meant was
i i try to always go
at least an hour after after that but um
but yeah as you said we got trained to
catch and apparently we have a dog who
recognizes our intonation well enough to
know she does uh that this this is the
sound of uh of people who are getting
ready to go off air and perhaps be uh
available to give a certain dog pets and
treats yes yes
all right really so we're we're done i
think so okay okay guys um apparently
apparently we are done for the week
we are going to take more than a
15-minute break this time we are going
to take a roughly seven-day uh break and
we will be back uh at the usual time
usual place next week and we will have a
live q a as well
and uh and you know bring bring your
questions bring bring anything you want
at that point yeah yeah yeah yeah bring
it
bring it your a
before actually before next week you
will have next saturday before our live
stream you will have the first of your
patreon no that's not next week at all
never mind um i was just shaking my head
because usually you know these things
and so if i shake my head i seem like i
know them too but yeah no i i gotta jump
on it there um it's the private q and as
next week uh so anyway consider joining
us um at our patreons and and jumping in
the discord and finding some of the
great people there if you want more more
conversation with people who aren't
interested in shaming you for having the
wrong opinion
because that is what you will find on
the discord server
so
without further ado
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside and achieve
greatness
[Music]